hello everyone and welcome back to the
chess 24 legends of chess final four
it's the other pair of the final
four uh yani pognish and anishigiri and
this is one of the games of their match
really an interesting
interesting one uh so let's just dive
straight into it
and uh in their previous previous match
up uh in the preliminaries of the chess
24 legends geary won their match so here
uh let's see if gary can do it again uh
so nipple with the white pieces
opens with e4 uh with e5 by giri and
bishop to c
for going for the the bishops opening uh
knight to f6
uh and the d3 now uh we have knight to
c6
and the knights to c3 uh we have bishop
to b4
uh now pinning the knight here nicely
developing preparing the castle
uh and uh nepo goes knight to f3 we have
d6 and castles and here
uh this bishop no longer serves any
purpose here
and uh well the knight can now move so
uh here just bishop captures on c3 it is
the most common move in the position
and it does make sense you kind of mess
up white's pawn structure
uh white will have some extra support
for for d4 in the future
uh but uh you you lost the bishop pair
however it doesn't matter because you
have this knight to a5 move which will
get rid of a white slide square bishop
as well at any point because black is
the one that
controls the tension and you haven't
really given up the bishop pair you just
uh you've just successfully messed up
white's pawn structure so here bishop
back to b3
and here we have h6 here gary just takes
away the g5 square from nepal's pieces
and now uh known moves here are bishop a
for check and rook to e1 we look to e1
in 2014 alexander grisham defeated
tomaszewski
in the uh video world rapid cup but here
we have h3 by nepo
and it is uh as of move 9 that we have a
completely new game
so let's see how gary deals with this he
continues developing queen to a7
he wants to get the bishop into the game
uh castle uh hopefully somewhere safe
uh and now knight to h2 preparing this
f4 idea and the geary doesn't want to
allow f4 so he pushes g5
saying that i probably uh sorry first he
captures on b3 and gets rid of the
a very strong light square bishop a
captures and now pushes this g5 idea
stops
f4 from white and says i most likely
will not be castling king's side
and i'm also very much interested in
playing g4 opening up the g
file and getting some sort of an attack
on your uh already castle king
so here uh nepo goes rook to e1 and
rook to g8 geary now prepares g4 and now
knight to f1 now with this g5 move uh
the f5 square
has been permanently weak and you don't
have the pawn here to control it so this
knight might be coming to squares like
e3 g3 and then later on maybe even to f5
or d5
so here g4 now threatening just to open
up the position and if you allow black
to do this then
uh black will have an excellent game so
of course nipple closes it
uh but now uh geary decides to uh
not allow this g3 move that will make
white's position perfectly safe
but rather to play a g3 himself and now
he gives up a pawn
but he he gets a semi-open g file in
return
uh and here the problem with knight
captures uh uh here is that you can go
knight to g4 and now you just threaten
to capture the pawn here
and if you advance that queen here and
goes after the h2 square
it's nothing spectacular white will have
an escape route here so it's not really
that big of a deal
but it's a bit too much maybe then you
want to allow black to
have so after g3 with f captures by
nipple
now defending the h4 pawn but now comes
rook to g6 and now
uh the game just continues uh uh giri
will try to
bring the bishop into the game uh hide
the king somewhere probably on d7 get
the rook into the game
and hopefully start an attack uh here we
have b4
uh just uh grabbing more space on the
queen side not allowing any a5 ideas
also black might have been considering
this
uh but here gary finds the excellent
knight to h5 or rather
maybe it's not so excellent he goes
after the g3 pawn
uh but also he gives up a knight why why
is he doing this
well the thing is if you capture the
knight then bishop the g4 traps the
queen
but there is a problem to this so uh
feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the move that nepal played
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting uh
the thing that we already mentioned and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
nepal played a queen captures on h5 he
gave up the queen
for the bishop and the rook and two
pawns he already grabbed one pawn now he
wants to grab uh two the two pieces
and he will also win the h6 pawn and
he'll he likes his position now being
down a queen here so gary traps at
bishop g4 and epo now goes for
queen captures on g6 with f captures and
now bishop captures uh
on on h6 so what is the evaluation of
this position well
white has two rooks a knight in the
bishop and black has a queen a rook and
a bishop however
this bishop once it lands for example on
g5 uh
will have an excellent outpost here you
will not be able to
to get it away from their control also
from here controlling f8 so rook is not
coming into the game via the only open
file on the board you will probably move
the knight play rook f1 double up rooks
here
on the f file and white's white moves
are very natural for black it's not so
easy to find moves
so king d7 preparing to bring the rook
into the game now knight e3 attacking
the bishop bishop goes back to e6
and now rook to f1 claiming the f file
we have queen to h7 attacking the bishop
and now bishop just goes back to g5 and
there's no way
for for the queen to enter the position
uh
in any way like you you could try
something like queen to h5 maybe trying
to infiltrate something like this but
why doesn't really why doesn't really
care or you can just even play g4
even ideas like this are still possible
if the bishop leaves the defense of the
square then rook f7 can can also be very
dangerous
so it's not easy to find moves with
queen to g8 now by geary
i i presume a waiting move and now rook
to f6 preparing to double up rooks on
the f file
we have a6 and now rook a to f1 and okay
for the moment
while this bishop is guarding the f7
square white
uh it is does not have all that easy of
a job of breaking through here so we
have rook to e8
and now just c4 preparing to uh
to put the knight on d5 where it will
either be an excellent piece or white
will have to give up this bishop
guarding the f7 square
so b6 by giri and now knight to d5 and
now the thing is if you if you capture
the knight
uh uh well if you capture black will
just capture
and now you don't have uh you don't have
a lot of moves here rook to f7 is coming
so it's a king here rook f7
queen somewhere uh the rook has no moves
the queen
has no moves it's just a very ugly
position to play for black let's say you
play something like this
uh you're going to play the other rook
to f6 now just threaten to win the pawn
if the queen defends it now you can even
push c5 bust open the position
and now let's say after everything gets
traded off now you're going to go bishop
e3 go after this pawn play c4
and so on and black is practically
without any moves here you are free to
do as you will
so after knight d5 we have king to c6
gary tries to hide the king
on the queen side and now rook back to
f2
now uh nepo will do some remaneuvering
he wants to play c5 but he first wants
to shift the knight over to c3
so queen g7 and now king to h2 first
a bit of a safer square for the king
guarding the g3 pawn
before committing to anything on the
queen side we have kink to b7 and now
knight to c3 so now you want to play c5
uh you didn't want to do it while while
the knight was on d5 to allow
this capture uh so first knights to c3
uh we have rook to a8 now maybe with
ideas of creating a pass pawn with a5
and now rook back to f6 attacking the
bishop queen g8 defending
and now finally c5 uh nipple busts open
the position
we have queen e8 you constantly have to
keep an eye on the bishop and on the g6
pawn
so knight to d5 now and now you're
putting a lot of pressure on this b6
pawn for example captures capture the
bishop e3 will put a lot of pressure on
it
so here we have d captures on c5 b
captures and b
captures uh geary grabs that c5 pawn
but uh in return uh offers the b
file for nepo's rook to control so rook
to b1 with
check and now it's a problem where do
you go with your king if king here then
just captures
uh forks the king and the queen and the
rook uh if you go king the
c6 uh then uh c4
followed by followed by well depending
on what black plays but
the thing is black doesn't have any
moves uh you can't go rogue b8 if rook
b8 you just trade for example captures
captures and you
lose the bishop the queen cannot move
from the defense of the bishop and
the pawn uh the bishop cannot move as it
spinned so you might try something like
king d7 to unpin the bishop
but now rook b7 is coming and there's
just there's just no upsides to any of
this
you can capture the one of the attackers
of the c7 pawn
he captures on day five you start
pushing your past pawn but now d6 and
black just falls apart let's say rook c8
you're going to capture here
captures and now rugby to b6 you're
going to capture this pawn and it's just
going to be a very quick
win for white so instead after rook to
b1 you can't go
here you can't go here uh geary decides
to go king to c8 but now comes
uh bishop to h6 just threatening rook to
f8 to win the queen
so king d7 but now you've basically done
the same thing only the other way around
so rook to b7
uh and here we have bishop captures on
d5
we have e captures on d5 and now king to
c8
i just realized i actually wanted to
increase the volume of the pieces
uh for this video and i didn't i'm gonna
add like uh five decibels
now just to see if it makes a difference
so you guys will we
will be able to tell there we go uh
and now rook back to b1 as the rook was
under attack
uh and here uh what are you gonna do
here
there's not much you can do uh we have
king to d7
again uh just uh trying to stay alive
but now rook
beat to f1 uh and here uh there there's
not much more you can do here the the
pawn is excellent here you're gonna play
c4 play
rook to f7 followed by rook to f6 which
will result in checkmate
or you're going to play rook to d8 which
is what uh giri did
but now feel free to pause the video
here and win the game in the quickest
way possible
uh well i'll give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding
the obvious rook to f8 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
rook to f8 so now the thing is the the
queen doesn't really have any good
squares queen to e7 was played by giri
but it was also in this position that
anish geary resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
uh just a rook
to f7 wins the queen and that's it
captures captures and the white
will be up a whole bishop uh and it's uh
there's not much to do europe a whole
bishop and the pawn so you know just
this this creates a pass pawn and this
one will will be dealt with
accordingly so uh very nice game by
nippo and the nipple was also able to
win their first match so we'll see what
happens today will
be able to retaliate or will we already
already have uh
our first finalist so once again i do
hope you enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh glenn mangold
priyam gupta dog mcnabb
colin cunningham and dan mc dan
mccormick for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
and a big happy birthday from jonathan
to all been a special request uh so i i
join in the
uh the congratulations i hope you have a
good one albin and
you know that uh ev everything you wish
for uh comes through
uh unless it's something really weird uh
so yeah uh once again uh i do hope you
enjoyed it as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and
i will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the legends of chess final
four
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
uh thank y'all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your saturday